[Applause]
[Music]
well i've always been different not
wanted to be different and
just the heels at a very young age was
just a great statement
for it what was that statement
i do what i want thank you
[Music]
i'm a french dancer choreographer
and i'm known i guess to be a man that
dances in heels
[Music]
now watch me run this
look at how i run this
the heels is definitely not just putting
a pair of heels and starting to dance
with them that's not
what we're trying to do we're trying to
really make it a new style
just as important as hip-hop jazz and
ballet
[Music]
i have choreographed signature humanity
i've worked with celine dion and ryan
reynolds
i was playing deadpool but in heels
i'm happy when people tell me that it
looks easy because it really isn't
when i dance i always try to make it
look effortless
the risk of dancing heels it's very
simple you can fall at any moment
i think the secret is never to forget
that you're wearing heels
when i teach i do tell my students that
it's not enough to be a good dancer
they have to be stars in their own way
they have to have
what i say the most is charisma yeah
yeah
i chose art because like many
different artists i'm sure it was just a
way of expressing ourselves
and dance was like my way of screaming
pretty much
or saying things that i couldn't now i'm
pretty outspoken
i wasn't always like that i think dance
helped me become like that
people would only focus on the heels
just the heels the heels and at some
point i was like it's not just
the shoe itself is what it represents is
the fact that men's are not supposed to
do it is the fact that if i'm going to
walk on the street with them people will
stare
you can't dissociate that being gay and
dancing in heels as a man you can't and
i think
some people have to do it so others can
feel like it's okay to do it
not just in your room i started very
young
my mother decided to put me up in a
professional training dance school
and as i was getting older i had my
sexuality happening so
the heels came with that i just think
it's a little bit
easier for sure to be gay now definitely
when i was 15 and where i was from it
wasn't
was not yeah were you dancing
no no but i was still gay
same
i didn't need heels trust me you're new
[Music]
[Music]
right left right left i've been told
that when i teach a class
that i also teach them a little bit
about life more than just dance
throw in front because i think it goes
together like
you can't be this great rebel dancer if
you're not like that in your life
i am like that the way i dance is the
way i am
i don't believe i'm the first man to
dance in heels at all
i think what i've done is made it very
okay
to do it i'm definitely aware of the
influence that i have
i only do what i do so i can inspire
people
[Music]
you